good morning John and good morning all
my chili American friends it's actually
a really nice here in Montana right now
and frankly it gets to like negative
twenty once every year here so I don't
know what everybody's complaining about
by frigid polar vortex polar vortex will
we're vortex
paulla vortex holer vortex a polar
vortex the vortex you are not my buddy I
would give you the finger but the time I
get my Snuggie
hardac polar vortex polar contacts I've
never heard of this thing where did it
come from why do we have a polar vortex
all of a sudden okay well polar vortices
are cyclones of air that exist around
the poles both poles and they're caused
by the temperature being different to
the equator that it is at the pole which
happens and has been happening since the
world existed all of the planets that
have atmospheres have polar vortices
usually we don't get the same little
offshoot that we got that dip down into
America and sat there for a little while
with colder in Georgia then it wasn't
Alaska it's weird I agree but the weird
events always make us talk about global
warming when really this is the exact
opposite of the way to think about
global warming saying that it's cold
here
that means Goble warming doesn't exist
is like saying I have a calculator which
is proof that jean-claude Van Damme eats
turnips I've been thinking about this a
lot because it's super annoying and I
think the problem is that global warming
is a terrible name for the thing that
global warming is it makes it sound like
things are gonna get warmer and yes we
are talking about an overall average
increase in global temperatures the
amount of temperature increase that
would be truly disastrous on a global
scale is like not even noticeable on a
local scale the planet heated up four
degrees Celsius that would be a disaster
but if your town heated up four degrees
Celsius no one would even talk about it
the scientific community is more
interested in calling a global climate
change because that points out that it's
not just about warming all sorts of
things are gonna happen it's gonna get
warmer in some places and colder another
place it's not gonna rain in place it's
like it's gonna fit the entire client
but I think that doesn't really get at
the real problem here the real problem
isn't with the climate change or the
warming it's with the global we are
terrible at thinking globally it's just
really it's impossible to do okay I got
an idea everybody get a pen and a piece
of pay
I'm gonna write down as a fairly
informed person a member of the people
who think about things a lot what
percent of the world's area I think the
u.s. takes up now I'm gonna look it up
okay I said five percent which I thought
was like a good underestimation of the
size that I think the u.s. is it is in
fact 1.9 percent that's the whole United
States including Alaska which is really
big I mean we know that we're not the
center of the universe but do we really
know that it doesn't seem like it so
here's how I think about it I don't
think about the weather when I think
about global warming I don't think about
the climate when I think about global
warming global warming is just an
overall increase in the amount of energy
trapped in the atmosphere and that
energy can be trapped as evaporated
water or wind or heat or hurricanes or
polar vortices it's just energy and the
amount of energy is increasing no one
can argue with that and as the amount of
energy increases the globe warms on
average and the climate changes hug
meted as energy separates it from that
thing in my head and allows me to think
about it the way that it actually is
rather than applying it to my everyday
experiences which have nothing to do
with anything global not that average
global atmospheric energy increases a
super catchy name or anything but that's
how I think about it and I feel like
people would be more accepting of the
idea if we talked about it as an energy
increase I could be wrong and I'm not
gonna change everything with a video
blog but that's how I think of it and I
thought I would share John I'll see you
on Tuesday but first here's some stuff
from my photo shoot wearing Alex days
clothes
[Music]
look at Hanks face it's my face look at
Hanks face